the Royal Albert Hall is one of the most
famous and prestigious concert halls in
Britain and the world it's 150 years old
and basically every world famous
musician in band has performed here at
some point the trouble is the science of
Acoustics wasn't really well developed
back in the 19th century a tall
oval-shaped Auditorium with a domed
glass roof well it looked impressive and
Regal but it created an accidental Echo
chamber the exact opposite of the
focused sound that you'd want for a
concert beautiful location terrible
sound to see how they fixed it we need
to go up to the parts that the public
aren't allowed into it was constructed
without any thought to Acoustics really
but it was also glazed it was Daylight
naturally lit a prince of Wales who
became king Edward VII made a speech
there at the public opening everyone
heard his voice twice so immediately
they had to do something to solve the
Acoustics and they install what's called
a Calico Valerian it's like a sail cloth
hung from the roof it was partially
successful the inner glazed roof
suffered from leaking broken glass panes
as a result of the second world war and
also daylight really wasn't suitable for
a modern Hall the inner glazing of the
Dome was removed and replaced in 1949 by
a aluminum valerium which is what you
see there now in the late 1960s the now
iconic mushrooms were added to the hall
they are suspended convex diffusers and
they helped cut down the echo tremendous
Loop in 2019 the sound system was
replaced completely within the hall and
the subjective response the reaction
from audiences has been absolute
tremendous this is right at the top of
the hall that is the glass roof it is 40
meters down to the floor
and just through there is an air vent
called the Corona and running across it
is a tensioned steel mesh to let the
technicians access it I am assured by
the team here that it is Fail-Safe and I
can walk on it
guy hello hello welcome to the corona oh
it's a lot colder in here
it must be oh I looked down
I should not have looked down I mean
your health and safety officer here
right that's right yeah you're just
casually standing on the mesh yep
feel free to step out with me that's a
that's a full fear response from me that
that's I was going to say is there
anything I can grab onto I was gonna
that's very greasy so most most people
hold my hand
including the fire brigade I was gonna
ask like who has to come out here oh my
God it bounces it bounces who has to
come out here uh technicians
um people who need to put shows on and
rigging
putting all my weight on that foot is so
so difficult bloody hell
oh my God don't bounce the weight of the
Royal Albert Hall roof the the dead
weight of the wrought iron structure is
about 340 tons the roof itself in total
can take about a thousand tons inclusive
of all permanent and imposed loads such
as wind and snow loading there is
approximately a hundred motorized chain
hoists which hang from the original
wrought iron structure of the roof which
vary in their load rating but some can
carry up to one to two tons of show
infrastructure we have lighting rails
which support lighting sound speakers as
well as the mushrooms which provide the
acoustic dampening of the auditorium the
mushrooms despite their quite
substantial size only weigh around 40
kilograms all of the mushrooms show
infrastructure speakers is all hung from
the original wrought iron roof structure
I I'm not sure I can move right now
I'm genuinely
just look forward just look forward and
walk just walk there's no way you can
fall there's no way you can fall just
walk look just look at the pole and
that's it you've done it Well Done thing
is congratulations thank you
it's it's all I know it's all in my head
because the poll is connected exactly
the same as this grid is so this is the
Corona the crown uh and uh that is the
Oculus above us
it's creaking that's the heat expanding
so the temperatures are regularly in the
30s and 40s typically whenever there's a
full from height risk the factor of
safety on the material properties that
would go into the design of the tension
wire grid is five to one which means
there's a five-fold weight allowance of
the material property which it can
support but the most surprising thing of
all about this roof is not how they fix
the Acoustics it's not this terrifying
tensions trampoline it's just out there
and the best way to see that is from the
outside I'm going to need a hand I just
pull through ah
ah the roof was constructed in full in
Manchester and then it was dismantled
and reassembled in London through
internal uh scaffold Shoring from the
inside of the hall every beam and
element of the wrought iron trusses was
then winched up to the top of the roof
and then assembled in situ the Shoring
was then removed once the roof had been
completed in full and dropped about by
about 5 16 of an inch or about eight
millimeters which would have been a
heart stopping moment I think for all
those involved all of which leads to the
most startling thing for me the reason I
made this video this roof this iron and
glass Dome with all that equipment
hanging from it it's not actually
connected to the rest of the building
it's touching sure it's resting just
here you can see where the two
structures meet
but there's no cement no bolts no
attachments at all this Dome is just so
incredibly heavy that it's not going to
move and it hasn't for 150 years 600
tons of iron and glass and a load of
Victorian engineering it doesn't need
anything more because anything powerful
enough to shift this wouldn't be stopped
by a couple of bolts the roof of the
Royal Albert Hall
isn't actually attached